Abraham's with us in Fort Worth Texas hi
Bram how are you hello Dave are you
better than I deserve sir
how can I help well I'm excited to hear
that better than I deserve
Dave collection collection call from
American Express oh and they said up and
so I stopped paying because I'm out
working and I was paying them $10 I
think the payment was 40 so I took phone
calls from them and they said give us
well we can take the money out of your
chart there's extra I said no absolutely
the moment I'm having trouble hearing
you're breaking up
you said what now you said you said you
owe them money you're paying them $10
and then what happened okay so the
payment was $40 okay so I said I'm not
working I said I sent them King for two
months and so I get a phone call they
said okay you're behind and if they said
give us let us just go ahead and take
$25 out of your account which you are
behind I did no good and I said and I
said because I've listened to you until
I said I'll send you the money so I get
a phone call today they said okay well
give us access and we'll take it out I
said no I will I will do it myself
I'm not giving you access okay so what
if what I mean what do I do about this
okay you don't give them access on your
mail you get don't give them access in
your mail on my check here's the thing
it doesn't really matter what you do
until you pay them off look they're
gonna whine right and gripe because
you're not paying them what you've
agreed to pay them you know right and so
no do not allow American Express to have
access when you are in collections with
them to your checking account they will
clean you out they lie right you can
tell they're lying if their mouth is
moving right and so you know they're
just scum and so hope I want unclear you
were doing the right thing now here's
the thing you're not working and
how much do you owe these guys I own
probably I don't know maybe 2,000 bucks
make okay okay but so what is your what
is the the answer to the equation is
income and paying them two thousand
bucks and that makes these people go
away for the rest of your life thank you
Jesus right so what is the process
what's your career goals what's your
working situation tell me about that
well I'm not working right now why I'm
pissed
well I'm looking for a car okay all
right well what did you use to learn I
was dry I used to drive a hobo and so I
quit that because it was just not
panning out for me and and so and I did
work at a call center for a little while
so and so now I'm looking I'm just
looking for something else
and how long have you been working up
about three months and how are you
eating well I'm leaving because people
help me out okay wasn't over at least
putting eating money on your table well
I mean some days are good some days are
not no right now you got nothing but no
good days you're right okay so while
you're doing I don't think you owe
nobody does something right you're right
so but you know nobody was it was the
malice that I was putting on my car was
this it was dead you know unbelievable
and so it just I didn't I didn't see the
same thing doing that okay yeah you need
to find something else today that you're
doing to make money you can deliver
pizzas every night and make $1,500 a
month while you're looking for jobs
during the day all right
and you can be doing that job by the end
of the day someone will hire you to
deliver pizzas by the end of the day I
mean once I do that so once I do that
how do I start to manage my money and
budget because that's what I don't
really have
handle all right well you first thing we
have to do is create some money coming
in so there is something to budget and
that's looking for a full-time gig even
though it's not a perfect gig you got to
get you got to get the wolf away from
the door you got to get back up on
survival mode going again okay and and
so we got to get delivering pizzas or
uber or something by the end of the day
today and that puts 1,500 bucks in the
pot in the pie where are you living
okay no I mean how are you living how
are you paying rent
who let you live for you really I'm
sorry
I'm stealing somebody okay so you got a
friend that's just letting you hang out
yeah okay cool so you don't have rent
costs today so as soon as you start
making money what you've got to do is
put gas in your car food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
once you've taken care of those basic
necessities of life in your budget
because and you and you start building
up more and more money because you're
doing more and more work then you start
paying down your debts how much debt do
you have other than a max filing about a
hundred thousand on what pretty cards
credit cards okay and how did you run up
a hundred thousand dollars on credit
cards oh well going with you always talk
about little stupid were you not working
what I was working in yeah I was working
okay yeah I was working okay so let me
let me propose something to you and you
tell me if I'm wrong okay I think it
might be that you're not working much
because you're so overwhelmed by this
that you don't feel like you're gonna be
able to get out even if you worked your
butt off well yeah there's kind of a
hopelessness bit mixed in with that much
credit card debt how far how far behind
are you with that credit card debt I am
NOT
okay and how old are you
fifty yeah 5-0 okay
and do you have a degree well I went to
electronics school for two years I used
to do I used to be electronic technician
years ago so if you could be anything
you wanted to be and we could snap our
fingers and blink our eyes and you would
be that what would you be today what
would I be today career-wise probably
like it's working at Southall center
maybe I meanest incontinence before and
I make good money managing Palestinian
know managing a call center okay all
right good that's not bad all right
what's the best you've ever made doing
that yes I've ever made was the hunger
cells
good okay well if you can get back into
that role over a period of time you can
clean up your debt really fast couldn't
you yeah okay but there's a lot of other
stuff going on in your life here dude
and this the credit card debt and the
other things the phone calls you're
getting are blistering you and they're
overwhelming and it's kind of taking a
little bit of your confidence away I
remember when I went broke I was a
little younger I was 28 but I took all
that it took all the swagger out of my
step you know I lost all my confidence
for a little while that might not be you
but that's how I felt
that's really mean because I feel like
you're my little brother big brother
hmm all right well you can do this so
what you need it what we got to do is
what I would do is set the credit card
debt aside mathematically and
emotionally for a little while and if I
were in your shoes Abraham I would
concentrate on Abraham because dude
you're a guy who's made $100,000 a year
before that means you're not stupid and
it means you're not lazy but you are all
that you are off the rails right now and
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna work
my tail end off if I'm you I'm gonna
take like 16 jobs and just
start just start piling up money there's
something about activity and a little
bit of traction that starts to give you
your confidence back a little bit at a
time and then land yourself back in even
if you start working for free at a call
center just get your foot in the door
improve prove that you're a stud again
and get yourself moving but let's get
some income coming in even if it's
stupid income for a short period of time
and I don't care if you're working 80
hours right now you're spend a whole lot
of time on a pity party and I don't
blame you I understand how you got there
I was there too but you can do this and
I'll make sure you're plugged into a
good local church as well while you're
doing this and don't allow Amex to have
electronic access to your checking
account in the mean time hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]